I just want to let you know that I'm
watching this past weekend tonight
Monday March 24th you asked for our
opinion on the corona virus and I wanted
to let you know that it has affected my
life some because work has slowed down a
lot people are worried about getting
laid off but at the same time people
worried about getting laid - damn I'll
tell you coronaviruses locked up all of
the wasps a and we NER that there ever
was man
JC bruh JC to the max Dawg he just flies
homeward but we were you talking about
brother I'm I'm not scared because I
have you on this past weekend I'm sorry
man I'm gonna go back on your call
because I interrupted it kind of with
being perverse really honestly man so
let's go again
first and I wanted to let you know that
it has affected my life son because work
is slowed down a lot people are worried
about you laid off but at the same time
I'm not scared because I have you on
this past weekend and canyons thing and
everything's been going good as far as I
can know because my kids are gonna be
taken care of and everything's just good
I mean I'm gonna interrupt you man but
because this you know when you say your
kids are going to be taken care of
that's oh this is something that a lot
of people aren't saying you know I see a
lot of people right now blame in the
government our government we don't have
enough masks we don't have enough masks
boy
well what if nobody knew this was gonna
happen people say well they knew and
this and that and here's the thing if
you have children if you have yourself
that's your responsibility the
government it's not the gun the
government is just people it's our
responsibility to take care of ourselves
the government is just a little is just
a severe an intricate stack of systems
that's all it is run by people human
beings we you don't have so your kid
doesn't have a mask you don't have
enough food stuff at the house that's
your fault I don't have bottled water I
don't have a kool-aid powder you know
what I'm saying I don't have a sack of
almonds or a sack of um hazelnuts that's
my fault oh there's not gonna be masks
for our kids there's not that if you're
a parent that's your fault
it's not the government's responsibility
to take care of you you had children
you need to have [ __ ] at the house in
case they're hungry I'll just add this
bowl I get just people share all of
these this man you don't owe they ain't
even got the damn uh much my boy lo uh
little Derrick yeah ain't even had a
biscuit in a month well [ __ ] get him
a biscuit then you know I know that
there are like um I know that like you
know people run out of money I'm not
trying to be insensitive to that I know
that you know that people don't have
unlimited that people don't have
unlimited what does it call when you
things like a group of things P
resources I know that but if we're not
it we have to be prepared for life I
think that's it we're I think we're
really lucky right now a lot of us are
getting a learning lesson like I don't
you know I don't have children and this
and that but if I don't if I'm not
prepared that's my fault you know I just
get it just the finger-pointing to me
gets really and in the news channels too
you know I don't watch a lot of the news
I see some of it on my phone and I'll
put the apps on and take them off but
and on Twitter just it's like wow the if
you've the second you start expecting
the government to take care of you
you've already lost cat daddy
so yeah just like what I'm saying is and
I need to be more constructive here even
for myself it's all responsibility if
you have a child and your child does it
you know something goes down and you
can't you you don't have something for
your kid what are you gonna look in your
kids eyes your kids like dad dad what a
dad you're gonna tell you kid all the
government the government man no you
you're the government for your child
you're your child's government so you
rave you Abe Lincoln in your house so
you gotta tighten up you know in - sorry
I didn't mean to jump on but this [ __ ]
got me fired that ship just man that
boils my that boils my beef bruh it just
boils my beef man when everybody you
know they should have people should do
why didn't we we should have done this
well I'm telling you we're doing now
it's are you as a human I'm not gonna
lay there on my deathbed like oh man the
government didn't they didn't have
enough mass for this or that I they
didn't have enough oh they didn't I
didn't get that bag of oatmeal from them
well well bruh get you out meal
this is a practice run for everybody if
[ __ ] got really really wild
if the interstate turns into a damn
waterslide it could get wild man so I'm
gonna saying this is your your kids
government's all responsibility man I'm
rambling but you know what you feel what
I'm saying I just don't like that extra
blame [ __ ] man I just don't like it and
I know that I'm not saying people don't
need to be subsidized and it's not
helpful and this is a great time to help
each other but you know just that man
brought it up that you know he is
fortunately you feelin okay and you know
his kids are okay and we have to be our
own governments as well you know this is
teaching me I have to prepare I have to
have the things in place that I need and
I'm grateful that there's this grace
period of time when things are
comfortable enough to gut the there's
still enough money where there's still
enough of a government can give people
money and we were really fortunate right
now you know I don't know if this is
happening in every country around the
world but I know that in America right
now that the government is saying hey
we're gonna mail you some money man I'm
pretty fortunate I need to work on my
gratitude man yeah I didn't mean to get
all just [ __ ] got me bent up but anybody
could get it okay
oh I can rollerskate you know my dad
used to roller skate I can't get it you
could get it wheels alright you could
get it out there and who the [ __ ] is
still rollerskating bro you could get it
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one